hello future Tech Enthusiast and curious
minds welcome to Simply learn where we
unravel the mysteries of digital world
today we have got an electrifying
episode that's bound to spark your
imagination and potentially change the
way you perceive the power of artificial
intelligence have you ever wondered if
there are AI tools out there that are
not only free but also seem too good to
be true well you are in for a treat
because in today's video we are diving
deep into the realm of AI magic but
before we unravel these technological
wonders make sure to hit the Subscribe
button ring the notification Bell and
join our incredible community of tech
Enthusiast so grab your favorite snack
sit back let's explore the Wonder of AI
tools that are free seemingly
unbelievable and just might be the key
to making you Rich are you ready let's
dive in when utilizing AI for Content
writing professionals must be very
Vigilant in maintaining ethical
practices and ensuring the originality
of their work relying too heavily on AI
without proper understanding and
integration of personal insights may
lead to plagarism concerns institutions
employ Advanced plagarism detection
tools and student risk academic
consequences if their use of AI results
inadvertently submitting content that
closely resembles existing Works student
and even professional working as content
writers might also find themselves in
this problem worry not we have got the
perfect solution that you have been
waiting for the uneducable AI is one
such tool that can help you out all you
need to do is copy the content from any
AI generated platform like chat GPD
bench or B and dump it on the
undetectable AI prompt the platform is
so powerful that it instantly identifies
plagarism and AI generated content and
quickly replaces it with other
Alternatives it checks the tenses and
voices and and irons it out to be most
humans as possible brilliant right check
out more about undetectable AI next if
you could easily obtain a voice just
like yours with Cutting Edge AI
technology effortlessly eliminating the
need for this extensive recording
efforts what you could just say a
goodbye to tedious recording sessions
and embrace the Simplicity of generating
your own AI voice in no time yes what
you just heard is a real thing let me
introduce to you descript descript is
your One-Stop solution to automate the
AI to identify and replicate your voice
just like yours or even better you can
train your AI and just drop your scripts
descript will identify tones and help
you with the best voice over with the
minimum repetitions and almost
nullifying the editing task following
that we have zier navigating the
rentless demand of crafting numerous
emails daily one find themselves caught
in a Perpetual cycle of communication
for clarity amids the chos but what if
say there's one tool amids the chaos to
help you automate all your emails Excel
task and any routine redundant task like
a breeze yes zapier is one such tool and
can write cover letters emails respond
your emails and do your daily office
course easily so much so that you might
not need to hire someone check out the
link in the description about zapier to
know more up up ahead we have byw
managing SEO often involves grappling
with the everchanging algorithms of
search engines making it challenging to
maintain consistent visibility
furthermore staying updated on industry
Trends and implementing effective
strategies amidst constant algorithm
updates demand continuous effort and
expertise byword is one of the
outstanding AI tool that can help you
with managing your SEO and keeping it in
line with the algorithm updates and
ensure that your page ranks on top every
time with with minimum efforts for more
details on byword check out our
description now the next one would be a
no-brainer you definitely want this out
in your day-to-day life facing a
speeding ticket or any legal issue
without the assistant of a lawyer can
lead to significant challenges without
legal representations individual May
struggle to navigate complex legal
procedures risking harsh penalities
increased fines or even suspension of
driving privileges introducing do not
pay your AI lawy who can help you out of
these hectic lawsuits with perfect
suggestions and solutions the link in
the description will take you to your AI
lawyer the next one if exclusively for
oneman Army content creators who create
record and edit their content is autopod
recording your own videos present
challenges such as maintaining
consistent eye contact with the camera
and it's easy to become distracted or
self-conscious this lack of direct
engagement can lead to disconnect with
audience impacting the overall
effectiveness of the video additionally
minor glitches in the end result such as
technical issues or awkward pauses can
deminish the professional quality of the
content hindering the impact on viewers
AI tools like autopod can automatically
record videos from different angles
different Lightnings and captures your
eye contact the tools can even
manipulate the places where you miss the
eye contact with your viewers and edit
the video in such a way that it looks
like you never missed looking into the
eye of your audience check the link
below learn more about autopod next we
have something for social media
influencers hunting to draft that
perfect clickbait option captions plus
logo crafting catchy phrases and caption
for social media post can be challenging
due to the need for bravy and constant
pressure stand out in the sea of content
balancing creativity with Clarity is
difficult as an overly complex or vake
message may fail to resonate with the
audience captions is an AI tool that is
is buil to assist you with mind blogging
captions that will compel your audience
to click on your page links more on
captions in the link below now let's
move on Eighth on the list today stable
in a world inundated with creative ideas
a sketch to image service is an
essential Lifeline bridging gap between
imagination and realization this
invaluable tool not only transforms
handr Concepts into polish digital
assets but also serves as time-saving
Marvel sparing creat ERS the laborious
process of manual digitization stable
doodle is just the right tool for the
job the sketch to service stable doodle
leverages the latest stable diffusion
model to analyze the outline of a sketch
generate a visually pleasing artistic
rendition of it for more details please
check out the link in the description up
next we have one for the students and
scientific Scholars that is s summary in
the ever Landing realm of research and
information the desperate need for
efficient assistant arises as individual
grapple with the overwhelming volume of
resource pages and scientific articles
time is a precious commodity and
streamlining the process of digestive
vast amount of information is crucial to
accelerate progress and Innovation size
summary really comes into its own with
two key features firstly there's bulk
summarize where you can upload a list of
all articles you would like some rised
and then these will be processed allog
together to know more about this savior
check the description next is run
diffusion if you wish to explore more
advanced tasks such as training a custom
image model or utilizing deorum for
video blending delving into the open
source model itself becomes necessary
ENT the diffusion a tool I have been
using for some time offering a
simplified way to run Advanced image
prompts and explore the capabilities of
both image and video AI with run
diffusion you can execute stable
diffusion in the cloud accessing
pre-trained plugins like control net and
de Forum as well as the variety of pre-
trained art models that can be
seamlessly switched between and there
you have it fellow Tech Adventures the
world of free seemingly unreal AI tool
is vast and full of surprises I hope you
enjoyed this eye opening exploration
thank you for joining us on this
thrilling ride until next time keep
dreaming keep exploring and may the
algorithms be ever in your favor until
next time signing off shingu an exciting
journey into the digital unknown stay
curious stay tevy goodbye for now
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here